border agents intercepting nearly 200
migrants
illegals by the arizona border on
wednesday 147
of them kids this just days after fox
captured this footage of nearly 300
migrants
illegals trying to push their way past
border patrol in
texas former arizona national guard
general and arizona
senate candidate michael mcguire joins
us now to react michael thank you so
much for being here
we see these images we see these numbers
uh you're running for office to do
something about it what needs to be done
now to deal with this situation
hey good morning pete uh thanks for
having me um
what needs to be done right now is we
need to secure the border we need to
build the wall
provide money to surge the guard to the
border
biden is derelict in his duty not doing
that
and you can see 147 of 200 nearly three
to one
this is organized by the cartels it's
what we've been saying for the last four
months
it's human trafficking and drugs at the
southwest border
our communities are less safe border
security is much more than national
security
it's human security here in arizona you
know the federal government we've seen
is not just not building the wall
they're taking it down or stopping the
construction of it
what more can states or should states be
doing
well what we did here uh just prior to
my retirement as a commanding general of
the guard was we
added our guardsmen to local sheriffs
to allow them to increase public safety
in southern arizona and our borah
counties
but the problem pete is they can't do
immigration enforcement that's been
ruled on
that's a federal responsibility and
biden's not doing it
so biden's not doing it the national
guard can assist but not apprehend
and ultimately when you see this flood
we know the numbers of people
apprehended how much larger is the total
number of people crossing in your
estimation we see these massive
increases in apprehensions
but the got aways what do you know about
that
well what i can tell you is the number
uh just
in the last cycle 188 000 in one month
to give you some comparison pete in 2014
during the main surge under obama when
he did
fund the guard uh with 68 000. so nearly
a three-fold increase
and i suspect there's a lot that aren't
being apprehended and our communities
are
clearly less safe we're creating a
crisis and emergency down there
and if he revokes title 42 under the
public health that's quite a dichotomy
while they're
increasing public health restrictions in
california at the same time
quite a contrast if you're if you're
getting rid of that protocol on the
border
and then you're putting kids in dc
schools back in masks
by the way we should note to all of our
viewers you can watch
michael's speech you're going to be in a
rally tonight with president trump
at turning point action rally it's going
to stream live
tonight 6 p.m eastern you'll you'll see
both
general michael mcguire and others on
stage with turning point action as well
as
donald trump live on that stage only at
fox nation
thank you very much general appreciate
your time thanks beaton go to elec mick
elecmic.com is our site and we will be
there tonight lots of energy with
president trump
first event in arizona thank you love it
thank you very much sir